but first let's turn our attention back
to the mob the media
over the course of the past few weeks we
did notice a sudden dramatic change of
heart among so-called journalists in the
press
after spending four years
hyperventilating every second every
minute every hour of every day
over foreign election interference all
of which has been proven to be false
the so-called journalists no longer seem
to care
for example look at this newly uncovered
eric swalwell scandal
the congressman was reportedly dating a
chinese spy
who apparently slept with a number of
politicians and according to reports
while we now know she was working for
the communist party of china
the same woman who bundled huge amounts
of money in campaign donations for
swalwell
well she also placed an intern in his
office i wonder if the intern was to spy
anyway swalwell sits on the ever so
important house intel committee
and he knows secrets that nobody else is
supposed to know
about china uh was there any pillow talk
now let me be very clear i don't really
give a rip about his personal life
the real question is is he compromised
by the way while we're asking that
question i wonder if joe and hunter are
compromised by
china did he reveal secrets did
she use his computer perhaps when he was
sleepy
but the new york toilet paper times has
not asked any of these questions
in fact they've not covered the story at
all not one single report
nothing pretty disgusting but always
predictable on their part
according to foxnews.com as of yesterday
fake news cnn msdnc
spent only five total minutes on the
scandal that shocked you
abc gave a whopping two minutes that's
because they have
george oh what's his name oh the clinton
supporter
uh stephanopoulos and nbc cbs they just
completely avoided the topic altogether
i wonder if his name was trump
how they would react but the bias of
omission doesn't end there
as you can imagine big networks also
have very little interest in covering
the hunter biden scandal as we know look
at media research
in the six days since zero experience
hunter announced
that he was under criminal investigation
over his
tax affairs the one they said no
credible person has ever seen anything
wrong with
no yeah that one anyway the network's
allotted a whopping nine minutes and 35
seconds of air time to the story
combined over six days i guess that's
slightly better
than they refused to cover the scandal
before the election
and told us that zero experienced hunter
making
millions and millions and millions and
millions of dollars was perfectly
legit and quid pro quo joe leveraging
bragging about it on tape a billion of
your dollars
demanding the firing wow of a ukrainian
prosecutor
investigating his son that was perfectly
fine too
remember this is a federal criminal
probe it's involving
money laundering the biden family
foreign corruption syndicate
and we'd call that international pay for
play schemes surrounding
what are sketchy foreign oligarchs
chinese nationals and other shadowy
figures
now the media mob they can't be bothered
turns out foreign interference isn't
exactly important to them
if they can't use it of course as a
political weapon against
somebody with the last name trump and as
kaylee mcinerney pointed out
this to this narcissistic bullies known
as the white house press corps
and needless to say they weren't exactly
pleased at hearing truth
about themselves and how well horrible
they do in the terms of their job
but they don't think they're great they
have that in common take a look
there was no coverage however of
swalwell being the one implicated with
not russia
but china in fact the new york times
website
as of this morning had not one result
for eric swalwell's ties to chinese
spies not
one result and when the swallow story
broke
guess how many minutes of coverage it
got on abc nbc
msnbc and cbs zero interesting
pre-election and post-election coverage
too
on the hunter biden scandal which was
not covered
at all by many outlets really
interesting turn of events
and good for those who covered what was
a story all along and not
russia disinformation isn't it critical
for you to accuse others of
disinformation when you spread it every
day
bye bye see ya fake news acosta
a few exceptions the entire journalism
quote
industry works on behalf of the
democratic party the state-run tv
and in case you were wondering virtually
no one has ever dared to ask joe biden
about the criminal money laundering
investigation
into his son and the biden foreign
family
syndicate corruption business or the
crack pipe
and yesterday when our own peter ducey
tried to get an answer
joe biden actually demanded that he be
congratulated
well there's no one else that shows up
for his events so why not go ahead
[Applause]
thanks for the con the congratulations
appreciate it thank you
that's the treatment you expect to
receive when you're a democrat
well just well wishes pats on the back
after all during the campaign the media
mob
they actively worked they let joe as the
campaign candidate protection program
propped him up didn't ask him a tough
question didn't vet him
accepted his lie on zero experience
hunter
and did the beating up of donald trump
every second minute hour of every day
when he could barely muster the energy
ah
hang on put my sunglasses aviators on to
get out of his own basement bunker
carefully
protected his image they concealed the
biden yup foreign family syndicate
business
they spiked a legitimate story by the
new york post
on hunter's laptop you know the one with
the crack pipe pictures
and i'm told worse i got a pretty good
briefing on that
it's going to get interesting now they
ignored the very serious claims from
hunter's former partner tony babalinsky
ignored the johnson grassley report went
into great detail of millions and
millions of dollars in wire transfers
from foreign nationals all to the biden
foreign family syndicate
and of course on the flip side they work
for four years to smear donald trump
haven used covid 19 in the pandemic to
score cheap political points they blamed
him
for each and every single death worst
pandemic since 1917
blamed trump they of course they called
him a racist when he enacted a
xenophobic as joe called a travel ban
against china
then bashed him for not doing it sooner
they were busy impeaching him
they even mock president trump for
accurately claiming the u.s
would in fact have a vaccine by the end
of this year
they scoffed at it joe biden told us
during the campaign there's not going to
be any miracles this is this is
bunk by the way are you uh junky
take a look
we'll have a vaccine by the end of this
year is that possible in your view
oh brian you know it's another day of uh
potus in wonderland here uh it is
preposterous
to make that statement that's an
ambitious timeline and many health
experts aren't so sure
it's achievable experts are warning that
kind of timeline may be overly ambitious
and some have even argued it's perhaps
dangerous will we get the best vaccine
in this timetable uh or will we just get
a vaccine a coronavirus vaccine trump
says it could come out this year this
sort of you know happy talk that he's
doing about a vaccine experts say
he'd need a miracle to be right here's
the thing you cannot talk yourself
into a vaccine the fastest a vaccine has
ever been produced from start to finish
is
five years journalism i said it in 07 is
dead
they don't care about facts they don't
care about truth they only care about
democrats winning elections
and even if they have to cheat that's it
that's the mission
fake news cnn msdnc abc
cbs nbc new york times washington
compost
that's eric pimple's paper he's obsessed
with us perhaps the most infuriating
part of it all
is they lie about their true agenda
we're honest we give news we do
straight news investigative reporting we
give opinion we do sports we do culture
we're the kind of like a full newspaper
they say they're news and news only
they give opinion every second of the
day well from their high
uh in their ivory tower pretending to be
fair arbiters of
truth they're not in reality lion brian
williams to dan
rather to fake jake to roswell rachel to
the genius humpty dumpty
some of the least trustworthy people on
the planet i think they actually believe
their own bs
now these are the same people telling us
to sit down and just shut up
accept those election results don't
question anything
they're now demanding that we unite
behind joe or else we're terrible
americans
take a look what i heard from joe biden
was
twofold one a bit of the same message
that he'd been communicating for several
weeks which is
one of unity and trying to calm uh
the passions of the election but also a
bit of impatience creeping in
you know we're now well over a month
after the election
this effort by republicans to challenge
the election has been
garbage the entire time they haven't
come up with anything
and i think what joe biden was trying to
say now that the electors have voted
this garbage stinks so bad
that there is no justification for any
of these
republicans to continue holding out
we've watched four years the mob the
media big tech democrats they never
accepted the results of 2016.
they lived in a fantasy world for years
full of delusions of russian collusion
ignoring hillary's dirty russian
misinformation dossier
that is a spectacular bifurcation of
their brains if you ask me